one of the top wide receivers in all of
the land getting set to hear his name
called on April 23rd because it will be
not a very long night for one of the top
wide receivers that Alabama has sent out
in quite some time
Jerry Judy here on the rich eyes and
show how are you Jerry well Jerry you
know what I'm doing fine thank goodness
I'm healthy I'm knocking on wood
everybody in my family is I hope
everybody is in your neck of the woods
is that would that be a safe assumption
hopefully okay well good glad to hear
that Jerry first things first
my bone to pick with you I'm a
University of Michigan Wolverine
graduate why did you play that ball game
against Alabama why don't you just save
yourself for the draft Jerry you know
I'm glad I'd like to compete so I just
want to go out there compute one last
time with my brothers Justin is
finishing off you're going million
expenditure t how he wanted to so I
wanted my career at Alabama as a loser
so I want to finish our wonder and play
one more game on my brothers right so
why did you not just step away then
after you scored that 85-yard touchdown
do you think you proved enough Jerry in
that game I just want to do a little
more respect that sort of work ethic but
I was very upset
Jerry very very upset very upset
watching that game but I guess you had
to do what you had to do right what's
the most upset you've ever seen Nick
Saban Jerry what was the most upset you
ever saw Nick Saban I guess somebody
bought him the wrong hat and cleared
seat so he's got a real real mad and
started yelling about his hat okay now
walk me through this what sort of hat
was it Jerry that's right I've seen
those uh-huh right and
I brought him there I get they were too
small he was like he did again and told
me you can't keep I think he was already
aggravating about others had a bad
practice so he just do it blew out of
proportion so it's one of those moments
where you don't want to laugh but you
had to laugh and you're trying to make
sure he doesn't see you laugh is that
one of those moments what about the most
angry you ever made him did that ever
happen Jerry that's a good one okay well
that's good well then I guess let me
flip it and be a little bit more
positive is what sort of coach is Nick
Saban to make you into the player that
you are about to hand off to the NFL be
in the situation by the way he just had
everything organized at Alabama to like
to make you become a pro Jerry Judy here
on the Rich Eisen show who's your
influence
who's your wide receiver influence
growing up or maybe over the last
several years who have you emulated
Jerry learning the game to receive I
might watch them fight Oh Calvin really
kind of really really talking a lot in
my game they said be and I wasn't like
are creepers Stefan did King Allen the
Varkey Adams guys I really know how to
run routes know the details of
fundamentals of outrunning know how to
manipulate the finish to make him say
they going hallway um machines like that
I learned a lot from ok
I didn't hear Julio Jones his name yeah
aren't you supposed to say that great
player but I mean I watched him a lot
but I didn't watch it but I like he hit
you see that he the big Tolliver six
four two two
ten run-ins 43 I yeah that's not me
that's not he's already watch him a lot
but he's a great guy loose yeah the six
one 192 pound at the combine jerry judy
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
what is your what is your I guess last
couple weeks that normally would have
been filled with a pro day and potential
visits what does that been like have you
been zooming with teams what is your
last couple weeks been like you know you
can't really do too much but at the same
time is like a time to work on yourself
so I didn't go anywhere to work out
whatever open and I just try to find
hope it still you know a lot of things
down here clothes so you're not working
out have you talked to teams huh have
you talked to teams specifically give me
some names okay yeah where are you right
now it sounds like you're outside Jerry
okay who's throwing to you who's
throwing to you John yeah Jerry did you
say you're getting thrown to by the
reigning Most Valuable Player of the
National Football League Lamar Jackson
is throwing passes to you right now work
out okay and a B is that is that a
Antonio Brown you're referring to so
okay so right now you're outside we can
hear the wind blowing you just stepped
off a field with who with Lamar Jackson
Antonio Brown and who Hollywood Brown
okay how many points could you put up
right now do you think the four of you
okay so what is what is Antonio Brown
look like Jerry what is Antonio Brown
look like describe so he is but he looks
as good as Antonio Browns ever looked is
what you're saying okay
and what advice is he giving you Jerry
is he giving you any advice work on
video games work on the little dinners
you won't throw that you need to work on
but that will enhance your performance
on the field like that and what about
Lamar what's he telling you keep working
hard and stay focused you know we
already know I got a level-headed
I'm level-headed just he know that I'm
gonna do what I'm supposed to do it to
get to where I need to go okay and so
this is all going down in the state of
Florida we're in Florida Lauderdale okay
Fort Lauderdale Florida and the great
outdoors hopefully not there's less than
ten hopefully your social distancing
right you're making sure you're six feet
away from each other we got to make sure
everybody's happy and healthy
certainly okay so before I let you go
here Jerry you know I'm I'm a
bar-mitzvah Jewish man very very rarely
do I bring that up with people but you
were ever starved David around your neck
correct Jerry you got that okay now what
now who gave that to you I got it myself
okay now why is that yeah you know
people call me juice so short for Judy
right but I just thought get a Jewish
star okay I just find that creative I
thought in my mind I did put a picture -
sustained
okay so she mean a lot to me just closed
along a bit night I love that that's
great so you're adding a little bit of
personal love to what
what's a wonderful symbol of religion
and also the State of Israel and for me
I mean if you need any you know tips on
being Jewish or Jewishness you can reach
out to me I will help you with that
Jerry okay no you got it absolutely
because we got to make sure again that
you gotta you gotta be somebody that
talks a lot about food portion size you
know long goodbyes the goodbyes are very
very long okay have you ever tried have
you ever tried gefilte fish Jerry have
you ever tried gefilte fish it's that
time of year too the first time I heard
of fish was all rush hour
[Laughter]
kinda like a feel the fish now we're on
the same page here now we got it working
all right Jerry appreciate the time
keep Telep tell those guys hello tell
him I said hi and Antonio Brown blocked
me on Twitter a long time ago so we got
to get that rectified if you want to
bridge that gap that's fine with me and
and tell until tell tell mr. Jackson I
sent my best okay you got it and and
once again I appreciate you calling in
and I just wish you hadn't played in the
ball game but that's just me Jerry you
got to do what you had to do thanks for
the time you guys that's Jerry Judy
everybody